[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the man of your
dreams
well welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy whose
videos send you to sleep in this episode
we're gonna be breaking down sandman on
netflix this is an absolutely
outstanding adaptation of one of the
greatest comic books ever written and it
proves that sticking to the source
material actually works rise sharoners
have recently used things like halo and
resident evil to tell their own stories
by stealth sandman embraces its beloved
franchise and shows that neil gaiman
knows best a film has been in
development hell since 1991 and it's
gone through the ringer with everyone
from james mangold eric kripke and even
joseph gordon-levitt attached in some
way that's all over now though the show
is here and the plot and ending have a
lot to impact from it this series adapts
the first two arcs preludes and
nocturnes as well as the doll's house
and going off what happens after that we
can pretty much predict exactly the way
the show's going to go i want to break
it all down but up top i thought i'd
talk about the comic property and some
of the easter eggs in it if you want to
skip ahead and see us tackling certain
sections in the video then time codes
will be linked below but i also hope
that you hit the thumbs up button if you
enjoy the breakdown now in case you
don't know the sandman is part of the
supernatural wing of dc along with
hellblazer and the sandman spin-off
lucifer the original work is filled with
nods to batman green arrow etrigan mr
miracle the justice league and it's
awash with dc characters that are sadly
removed from this entry this is
obviously due to casting and also rights
issues and who knows discovery could
have canceled the whole series for a
laugh if it had been on hbo max
now lucifer and constantine sorry
constantine appear in the show too with
their genders swapped so they don't
clash too much with the other
live-action versions out there lucifer
was originally based on david bowie but
gwendolyn christie brings her own style
to it and judging by the ending we'll
know that i'll be seeing her again very
very soon anyway the comic was
originally intended to be a revival of
the 70s character the sandman but gaiman
ended up creating a wholly different
version however the show does have some
easter eggs that call back to him when
jed dresses up in the original costume
other dc easter eggs appear in the
basement when jed suits up and these
include captain cold pied piper a
masculist psycho pirate a batman action
figure and also a flash one and the show
much like the comic starts with the
capture of dream by roderick burgess in
1916 played by charles dance burgess is
attempting to capture death so that he
can resurrect his son who died during
the first world war now in the series we
meet lots of the endless and for the
next part of the video i want to break
down who they are and also what desires
plan is the analysts are
personifications of concepts like dream
destiny death destruction desire despair
and also delirium they themselves also
have specific rules attached to them too
and they can't really interfere with the
lives of humans even though they often
do they're also unable to form romantic
relationships with mortals except again
dreamed as it anyway but i'll explain
that when we get to hell aka sunderland
having that now they're also not allowed
to spill the blood of their siblings
meaning that dream can't just kill
desire which is incredibly important to
the ending and desires plan
most also have their own domain with the
main ones featured in the show being the
dreaming and also desires home the
threshold a dream's capture at the hands
of burgess was taken advantage of by
desire because they resent dream desire
is an androgynous endless that can
appear as male or female due to being
gender fluid and they're played by
non-binary actor mason alexander park
who you may recognize from netflix's
cowboy bebop now episode 1 is a beat for
beat recreation of the first issue and
we even have specific shots and panels
that are referenced throughout while
dream is captured a sleepy sickness
sweeps the world with people either
ending up stuck in sleep or unable to do
it
this is important as a young girl unity
kincaid was unable to actually awaken
from her sleep which allowed desire to
start the part of their plan
unity was destined to become a rare
dream vortex which means that she
connects all her dreams and could
potentially destroy them it's important
to bear in mind that this is one of the
rare instances that allows dream to kill
a human and throughout the ages he
snuffed out the vortexes before they
could completely wreak havoc now unity
did not become the vortex due to dream
being imprisoned in the comics we
learned how this had a major effect on
the 20th century and it even led to
things like the second world war because
people were unable to dream at some
point later desire impregnated unity and
during her sleep she gave birth to
miranda which then led to rose this
means that rose became the dream vortex
but as she was technically a blood
relation to dream means that if he did
his job and killed her he would have
unknowingly committed a cardinal sin
against his entire family as we
mentioned earlier the endless are not
allowed to kill their relatives so what
desire is trying to do throughout the
season is put him in the bad books the
punishment for this means he'd be
hounded by the three witches who
themselves are based on myths and
legends now each episode on the show
roughly centers around an issue of the
comics though there are ones like
episode six which combines two
gaiman wasn't planning out these massive
arcs when he was first crafting the run
but in hindsight this allows the show to
introduce certain characters earlier
nowhere is this scene more than in the
corinthian played by boyd holbrook whole
season i was like is that is that him
and he completely sinks into the role
playing it like no other character that
the actor has taken on before just
before dream is captured he's unable to
unmake the corinthian who is a nightmare
that's gone rogue because he resents
being unable to interfere with the
waking world
roderick ends up being helped by the
villain so that he can cause chaos
without worrying too much about being
captured by dream now in his absence the
dreaming starts to fall into disrepair
and various streams of nightmares end up
escaping including fiddler's green
played by stephen fry in addition to
this dream's tools are taken from him
including his mask ruby and also his
sand these allowed rodrick and his
followers to live long lives but it all
ended when they were taken by his
mistress ethel crips
she fled because athel became pregnant
and rodrik wanted to terminate the baby
and thus she ran away before she was
forced to do it now this child became
john d played by david dulis which
changes things up from the comics
slightly in that his role was played out
by dr destiny and he was the one who
ended up in the diner issue which is
pulled across to the season destiny was
kept in arkham asylum in the source
material whereas here he's just in a
mental health facility that he escapes
from after getting the reverse uno chord
dream is freed when roderick's other sun
alex breaks the spell and finally he
takes revenge on his captors now
unfortunately they don't do the forever
waking curse that dream puts on them in
the source material it's one of my
favorite parts of the entire run and it
basically has a character having a
nightmare waking up panicked seeing that
everything is okay before that then
turns into its own nightmare forever and
ever and ever really horrifying fate but
they simplify it quite a lot here a
dream then goes to meet lucian and the
first part of the series is about him
getting his mojo back now other than
being near comics accurate thanks to
neil gaiman's efforts in pre-production
what's so great about this show is that
it truly feels like a tv show most
episodes have a beginning middle and end
and unlike other comic book streaming
shows we don't get this stupid six hour
movie thing that i think really hurts
character development and also pacing
now as part of his plan to get each of
his tools back he must consult the three
which are known as the fates or also the
kindly ones they're sort of like the
witches from macbeth though shakespeare
does appear in the series too we see him
making a deal with morpheus and in the
comics we actually saw that he went on
to craft midsummer night's stream which
got its own issue centered around it
this will probably pop up in season 2
but either way the three speak in
riddles and help him locate each item
eventually he gets them back and along
the way he encounters john d constantine
and also lucifer during his journey
through hell we see a woman reach out to
him called nada who we learn more about
in the source material a dream took a
mortal form and the pair ended up
falling in love with each other despite
it being forbidden according to the myth
the son saw what they had done and it
melted her city which led to her taking
her own life dream saw this as a
rejection of him and he condemned her to
hell eventually in the comics dream ends
up apologizing to her for the torment
that he forced her to endure and he
offers himself to her again whether she
once more rejects him savage but rather
than doing a henry viii he decides to
take the mature route and offers her a
place in the dreaming if she ever wants
it he ends up having her reincarnated as
a baby on earth which yeah good on you
mate only took three thousand years now
dream goes head to head with lucifer in
order to get his helmet back there's
also the mention of anti-life which
you're probably familiar with if you
know darkseid from dc comics constant
time will also likely pop up again and
if we get a season 2 then we could
return to hell for her to get back the
kid who ended up being trapped there
either way him getting back his tools
wraps up the first major arc in the
season and that sets things up for the
corinthian and vortex storyline to
follow episode 6 is my favorite in the
entire run and this puts together two
story lines from the comics namely the
son of her wings and also men of good
fortune i'm currently working on a full
breakdown of justice entry alone but it
beautifully adapts two of the best
issues in the source material so keep a
lookout for that one now the first part
has us following death as she goes about
her business and this shows dream that
he needs not to be isolated from
humanity and that he should find purpose
in his job on the opposite side of this
is the story of hobgatling who
dreambuilds her friendship with after
meeting him several times across 100
year increments we also meet one of
constantine's ancestors which ties back
to dream discussing how he'd met her
family before in centuries long gone now
along with them is so-and-so epic saying
centuries long gone now along with it
what an idiot now along with ebb is the
part of the season that brings jed and
rose into the fold the pair of siblings
with the ladder being forced to separate
from him this has led to her searching
for him and his storyline is very much
about a family reunion but they're also
finding some unity with unity hey who
can i write
anyway it's time for jared's easter
right corner
[Music]
okay so along with rose is her friend
lita and actually in the comic she's the
daughter of both wonder woman and steve
trevor her husband though goes one
deeper to the source material to a
character called hector hall now hector
hall is actually the son of hawkman and
hawk girl wait i thought that they were
brother and sister and he himself ended
up becoming a sandman in the comics now
hector in the show impregnates litta in
the dreaming and if you didn't know in
case you're wondering this actually
belongs to
well it's morpheus this will no doubt be
explored in a season two because this is
one of those things that you leave the
season just just wondering about like
what
[Music]
that wasn't actually that bad now the
corinthian wishes to use rose as the
dream vortex for his evil plans thus he
ends up kidnapping jed to make matters
even more complicated we learn that gold
has been using the child as well now if
he confused about what's going on with
her she's basically a nightmare that
wants to become a dream the comics
didn't really have gold and instead they
had brute and glob who were the ones
that were messing with jed's head
however what they had is the serial
convention which is a big event for
serial killers
the book expands on this a lot and we
discover that the corinthians spent a
lot of time on earth twisting people
into violent killers the source material
had a lot of forth wall breaking moments
in it as this was presented as a type of
comic-con and with the book being a
comic
yeah you get it right now rose is
accompanied by gilbert aka fiddler's
green and with gold back it's just the
corinthian that needs to return as
dream's last missing creation and whilst
rose's dream vortex gained strength
dream becomes vulnerable this is why the
corinthian tries to convince rose that
dream is the bad guy because she has the
potential to weaken him until the point
of death dream ends up coming out on top
though and he ends up destroying the
corinthian leading to the main villain
of the season being taken out at this
point the show felt a bit like the
return of the king extended edition thus
getting lots of different endings with
rose we watch as the dream vortex starts
to rage and this is why several of the
dreams start to collapse into one
luckily unity makes a sacrifice and
after taking rose's heart she becomes
the dreaming vortex which leads to her
death so that the domain can stabilize
now because of this desire's plans are
over and dream threatens the character
in a scene that's lifted straight from
the comics those have the pair
developing and an easy truce between
each other but i do hope that season 2
goes beyond that and that we see the two
clashing once more as desire is by far
the most mysterious villain in the show
funnily enough they were actually
dream's favorite sibling at one point
but animosity grew between the pair as
he retreated to a life of solitude now
lucifer probably drops the biggest tease
for an arc in the second season and we
watch them close out by saying they'll
do something that will make god angry
this also kind of goes against the
source material too as when we see
lucifer again in the comics they say
that they're ditching hell and closing
it all down however the show looks like
lucifer may lead to a hell war against
dream but what would make god far more
angry is lucifer leaving to go to earth
like the comics now when hell closed in
the source material lucifer ended up
choosing who to give a key to which led
to many different deities petitioning to
real hell as isil the creepy being that
speaks to lucifer was one of these so
expect to see them pop up once more in
season 2. now i would expect that we
follow dream as he heads into hell once
more to free his former love nada if the
show picks up on that hawk they could
also tie constantine in with that and
that seems to be the direction that the
show is going now with hell expanding
everything could end up being in turmoil
and it may be dreams forgiveness of nada
that makes lucifer stay their hand they
could end up seeing that forgiveness is
extremely important and possibly call
off the invasion close hell and then
continue like what we had in the comics
it's all gonna go down in season two and
as for this one i think there were some
really really strong entries here and a
lot that perfectly captured the comics
the opening episode dinah one and death
one were all excellent i think that
there's something fans are really gonna
like however i don't think it's perfect
and there are some bits here and there
that thing could have been better
explained for newcomers on the show this
includes desires plans some of the
realms and also more about what was
really happening with rose still though
what we got is one of the most solid
adaptations of the work that i think we
could have the show is standing at
points and is laced with so many cool
little details even things like signs
being in gobbledygook in episode a
because text and dreams comes out like
that shows how much attention to detail
that they were paying however i think
that the ending kind of dropped the ball
a bit with us getting half an hour of
teasers rather than a climactic end to
everything the corinthian kind of went
out in an understated way and i just
wish there'd been more of a focus on
that rather than the vortex and the
10-minute lucifer scene still i'm
complaining about very minor things in
the grand scheme and hats off to those
involved for bringing us the best
adaptation that i think we could have
got i'm not really seeing tom sturridge
in much but he brings a very somber slow
talking dream that has a great presence
to him he's enigmatic and though he's
probably difficult to relate to he's
arguably one of the best portrayals of
an entity like this that we've ever had
i really hope that the show is popular
and i think that those who love the
source material will find a lot to like
here netflix are pretty ruthless when it
comes to cancelling things but hopefully
they actually give this a chance so we
can get the full arc as it does get
better and better in the end i'm gonna
score a solid 8 out of 10 which has dips
due to the way that things were wrapped
up still low entries like episode 6 had
me crying throughout well not me
people i know my friends my cousins they
were all crying and it's something that
i'll probably revisit a lot as its own
standalone thing i'd obviously love to
hear your thoughts on it so make sure
you comment below and let me know we are
in a competition right now and giving
away three copies of doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness on the 15th of
august and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the series
we picked the winners at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one on
screen right now so if that's you
message me on twitter spoilers if you
want some emails to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of prey
which will be linked on screen right now
absolutely brilliant movie loved it and
we go over all the details in that in
case you want to know more about the
property by the way thanks for sitting
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time take care peace